happy Saturday the octaves oh-oh
not believe we're already rallying we
were out to like 5:00 a.m. yesterday Oh
last call you know what that means
you're gonna try to text Bryan yep oh my
god
what I texted time I texted Bryan when
earlier today when I was sober I sober
texted him this is this is really
embarrassing
what did you say it's pretty articulate
should I text let me get in and say
that's not who I am at all okay no I
think you should send him like a super
drunk selfie and like a wink face it'll
like bounce everything out and maybe
he'll forget you know all about that
other text that's so smart yes oh cool
that's done so Jesse have you been since
finding out you were adopted
not good oh my god Brian texted oh thank
god
it's a drunk booty call text we're okay
he said to ditch my underpants and come
over I can only assume he meant
underpants oh hey wait you said you were
gonna get this round Hey I'm sorry it's
so loud in here I can't she left us just
like your parents left you
okay let's take off her clothes wait
could we just talk about that text you
sent me wait wait no Ryan just forget
about the text I was just you know
rested and awake and it just kind of
came out I know I mean I get that but
some of the stuff you said I'm never
gonna forget it
it was a wild I mean look at this I
respect you why would you say that to me
I would like to get to know you better
in a new context if that's something
you'd be comfortable with that is the
longest sentence I've ever read listen I
promise that was my crazy like sober
rain I was just reacting to like the
existential loneliness that kicks in
when you're not totally numbing all of
your feelings are the substance so it
didn't mean anything
I don't know I just see you now as as
this three-dimensional person with
thoughts feelings and parrot oh my god
you probably have parents right no stop
stop
don't don't run what we have look I see
you as just you know a reliably safe and
reasonably enjoyable penis you're
basically a piece of meat to me just
face me you really mean that yeah
listen I want you to hear me and believe
me when I say I don't like you enough to
ever ever actually date you same yeah
let's just go have some mediocre sex and
then I'll fall asleep immediately I
would really like that oh wait you
really do like my paintings all right
[Music]
you